it's only March we're going to go ahead
and just declare this the best story of
the year so we told you about a
Tanzanian fashion designer who was
watching Fox news coverage of Sam
brankton that would be Joe Biden's
non-berry binary cross-dressing nuclear
waste expert who stole luggage off
carousels as part of his fetish so this
designer asea alcag noticed that Sam
Brenton was wearing one of her dresses
and we thought how great would it be to
track down this Tanzanian designer to
tell her story and we have she joins us
now with her husband come scene asea
thank you so much Compton thank you Asia
will you tell us what happened how did
you notice that it was your dress
I have Bismillah
thanks for inviting me to your show
my name is Asia idarus Ramsey
Tanzanian fashion designer based in
Houston Texas
on February 2018 I flew back from
Tanzania with my collection of Lady Red
fashion show 2018 which is my annually
platform
I was invited in Washington DC to Kenyan
Community event who really support my
work to Showcase my designs I flew from
Houston to Washington DC on March 9th
2018 when I arrived in DCA
one of my back was missing I opened the
claim to Delta office in DCA and I made
a police report in DCA airport but my
bag was not found
on December 2022 we saw on the Fox news
about Sam Brinton luggage issue and so
my custom-made designs World by Sam
Brinton which was in the missing big big
2018.
oh my God I was shocked for more than 40
years I work hard
on my work
it's very paining then I made another
police report in Houston
they told me to wait for investigation
on January somebody calling me called me
and introduced himself and he told me
he's working on my issue but still today
I had nothing
I was asking myself how this person got
my custom-made designs because it's one
of a kind and wear them without fear and
display in public I don't accuse him as
a thief but there is question to be
answered here what can I can say for now
with all pains time suffer let down my
people didn't attend the show
what I need is Justice now
and I believe there is justice well I
believe that too has he reached out to
you the man who clearly stole your
luggage Sam Britain has he called you or
returned these dresses
no
may I ask a question of your husband so
here you have this entitled little creep
who's a federal official stealing your
wife's clothing what's your reaction to
that and what would you say to Sam
Brinton if you could
well uh the only thing I can say you
know like a
um is painting and I was going through a
hardship you know like a
to try to calm her down and because this
is her passion she had been doing this
for 40 years
and all of a sudden somebody running
around with the you are you are
designing piece of art it's painful and
she asked me you know like I said well
you've tried whatever you've been trying
you know like if there is justice
let like let them hate about you you
know if somebody can step up and try to
help because without help you know and
this thing you know like I think people
think like it turns more into Political
which is not
you can't say green is is black or black
is Yellow Black is Black you know the
truth the truth wants to be you know say
you know yes so we think we think you
know we thank you to come to your show
and you know like maybe somebody can
outside they can hear you know
well I hope so acclaim
and I hope this this man gets a little
Tanzanian Justice uh honestly because
he's not getting in this country um so I
appreciate so much both of you coming on
and I'm sorry for what you've been
through and I hope that restitution has
paid to you both thank you very much
thank you so much thank you so much
but we are calling for somebody there to
if you can help out
yes
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight